It's been a long day. So we got some tacos tonight.
I got four hours of sleep last night.
Probably even less cause I woke up in between those four hours.
Um, so I'm not cooking tonight.
Okay. So we kind of always get the same order.
We can never get tacos without a horchata,
so we got one. I always tell lucky to just get one.
I always end up drinking the majority.
I get two every time she steals my drinks.
You got two this time? Yeah, mine.
I told you to just get one.
Well, I got two.
So excited. We always go to this tiny little Mexican place
that kind of looks like you wouldn't walk into it,
but it's so good. It's the best.
Oh yeah, baby. Oh yeah.
That's insane amount of salsa.
How many people do you think that they think that are gonna be eating?
Probably a lot. We've got cilantro,
limes and onions. We always need extra.
I don't know why this is cautionary.
Lucky uses so much lime, it's disgusting.
And hot sauce. So you don't taste your food?
No, I enhance my food with hot sauce.
Oh yeah.
My two tacos that I wanted to try.
What is this? Chorizo.
You've never gotten a chorizo taco before?
Never in my life. He's branching out.
Okay, this is what I got.
What is this? The pork?
Pork al pastor, I think.
Yeah. Yeah.
Tacos with just corn. I usually get Corn tortillas.
I don't do flour for obvious reasons.
You've got two trees of tacos.
Never had a trees of taco,
but you wanna see here. You wanna bite?
Take a bite.
You're unhinged today.
And then I got
steak tacos. Classic. Onion, cilantro,
corn tortilla.
Ever since I've known lucky,
he's only done steak tacos.
I remember when I first moved to LA,
he would take his little skateboard and go skateboarding to get tacos
at, like 1:00am.
He gets salt on the side.
So basically, lucky puts extra lime,
extra hot sauce, all the sauces,
extra salt on his tacos.
That seems criminal. That's actually.
Are you okay? I'm fully.
I actually wonder if I am.
I don't know. I like the green one,
whatever this one is. This one's really spicy.
This one is kinda more lemony,
I guess. Have you guys watched the Martha documentary?
I'm obsessed. She's so classic.
I made lucky watch it, but he didn't get fully into it.
He watched the first. No,
I did, but I saw what I need.
What I needed to see.
And then I was kind of done seeing people build stuff,
how they got from here to there.
I like the whole thing. It was classic.
Anyways, we're gonna go eat now.
Yeah, we are. Eat a few tacos tonight.